et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Renault Muselier bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous à Muselier président de
la région sud provençale-côte d'Azur
membre de Renaissance on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet
Ouest-France bonjour Stéphane bonjour
bonjour bonjour
et on commence parlant de la réforme des
retraites Renaud museliers Emmanuel
Macron était à Rungis ce matin à l'aube
pour défendre sa réforme des retraites
notamment dans l'ensemble les gens
savent qu'il faut travailler un peu plus
longtemps a-t-il dit et il en appelle au
bon sens des Français est-ce que le bon
sens c'est pas de retirer cette réforme
non je crois qu'il a parfaitement raison
tout le monde a bien compris que de
toute façon il fallait travailler plus
longtemps alors est-ce qu'on doit
travailler plus qu'est-ce qu'on
travaille mieux est-ce qu'on travaillait
pour gagner plus de moyens ou pour vivre
mieux de toute façon on peut pas être
les seuls en Europe à 62 ans
pendant que tout le monde est à 65
certains pays comme aux États-Unis c'est
71 donc il y a quand même un moment où
il faut réaliser que ces arguments de
bon sens le bon sens qui ont envie
beaucoup plus longtemps et mieux tant
mieux ça veut dire que les Français qui
s'opposent à cette réforme ils ont pas
de bon sens ça veut dire que vous n'en
soccer du bon sens c'est de dire si je
peux rester comme j'étais avant sans
travailler en moi et partir plus tôt
c'est du bon sens si vous savez quand
vous sondages et qui a 30 % de gens qui
disent moi je veux la réforme de la
retraite c'est quand même un vrai
miracle qu'on est 30 % de gens qui
disent le travail des hommes de plus ça
c'est la réalité néanmoins
si on regarde un peu l'état des lieux du
pays des pays la façon de travailler
notre qualité de vie voilà on a bien
compris qu'il fallait quand même
prolonger un peu mais différemment
sûrement c'est une bonne idée c'est une
bonne méthode de la part du président de
la République d'aller à Rungis pour
faire passer ce type de message ou on
n'est pas dans un dans une dans une
action de communication un peu décalée
c'est une action communication
incontestablement si c'est un message
c'est une bonne action de communication
c'est la bonne manière de faire en tout
cas il parle à ceux qui se lèvent tout
et qui travaillent voilà et qui se donne
du mal et ça va l'encontre de et c'est
un message très positif par rapport à
ceux qui qui se lèvent pas tôt et qui
travaillent pas mais vous pensez que sur
la réforme des retraites le la ce qu'on
appelle la bataille de l'opinion peut
encore être gagné par le gouvernement ou
c'est perdu quand est-ce quand est-ce
que le gouvernement a perdu cette
bataille sur quel point partir je crois
qu'elle a perdu à partir du moment où si
vous posez une question à celui qui pour
la réforme de retraite qui est
absolument capable de nous expliquer
pourquoi on comment et qu'est-ce qu'il y
a dedans en fait personne n'est plus au
courant de rien alors nous ici au Sénat
ou à l'Assemblée ou ceux qui sont des
observateurs éclairés ils peuvent voir
ce qui se passe au niveau de l'alinéade
je sais pas quoi de l'article 1 on sait
même pas les je fais article 7 en fait
de pédagogie de méthode de la part du
gouvernement c'est ce que vous dites ici
c'est mal pris la mal expliqué du
Parlement de l'Assemblée dans sa
globalité
gouvernement et Parlement le Parlement a
été en dessous de tout enfin l'Assemblée
nationale était en dessous de tout et
les messages ou vous ciblez un groupe en
particulier non je cible base je cible
en premier la lups qui quand même enfin
moi j'étais pas humain pendant et Dieu
sait si j'assistais beaucoup de débats
parce qu'on a vu est absolument
vraisemblable et incroyable et et un
qualifiable en fait par rapport à nos
concitoyens alors après vous avez des
postures elle est on sait pas s'ils
veulent ils veulent pas
le rassemblement national ils veulent
faire ils sont tous bien habillés
propres sur eux ils sont cons tout en
étant pour enfin c'est plus très bien ce
que veut ni les années les autres à la
sortie la seule chose qui compte dans
l'opinion publique c'est les 64 ans en
fait voilà et là on est même pas allé
donc heureusement échec total vous
parlez de l'Assemblée mais pas que de
l'Assemblée si je vous suis bien si je
vous comprends bien vous vous évoquez
dans une certaine préparation ou une
forme d'amateurisme de la part du
gouvernement vous pensez à quoi
précisément sur les 1200 euros par
exemple de sur les cariérarchiques pour
les femmes des choses comme ça on a été
mal expliqué en tout cas ça a été mal
compris donc on s'est mal compris ou ça
a été mal amené où ça a été perturbé
donc on sait plus très bien parce qu'on
sait plus très bien qui a dit quoi à
quel moment a été interprétée donc à
partir
de m'expliquer ce qu'ils ont voté ou pas
voté voilà vous me le présenter voilà et
donc dans l'opinion publique
de l'examen à l'Assemblée tu as perdu la
bataille avant même le début de l'examen
elle est perdue pour la durée mais elle
est gagnée dans la compréhension c'est
ça qui est particulier c'est ce qu'a dit
un peu le président ce matin comme c'est
à dire que tout le monde a bien compris
que de toute façon fallait passer mais
on n'a pas envie d'y passer
donc on essaie d'y passer de manière la
plus convenable possible est-ce que
c'est là qu'on comprend plus rien est-ce
que c'était le bon moment pour la faire
et est-ce que c'était la bonne méthode
vous avez dit tout à l'heure il aurait
peut-être fallu la faire différemment
non c'est est-ce que c'est le bon moment
on va participer c'est toujours bon
mauvais moment alors attention il faut y
aller donc
passionniste est-ce que c'était vraiment
le bon moment de faire
l'économie va bien il y a l'emploi pour
tous
euh on nous a expliqué toute la journée
qu'on allait plus avoir de l'électricité
c'est pas le cas qu'il y avoir euh un
désastre économique ce n'est pas le cas
euh donc globalement l'économie
française va bien quand même très bien
même mieux que les autres Européens donc
si on y va pas là maintenant on y va
quand alors bon donc pour le moment oui
pour la est-ce que c'est la bonne
réforme est-ce que vous vous auriez fait
cette réforme telle qu'elle ou est-ce
qu'il y a des choses à changer sur la
pénibilité sur les carrières longues sur
les femmes c'est la difficulté
d'exercice dans ce dans cette dans ce
Parlement
moi j'étais député et député européen
parlons européen vous pouvez ne pas être
du même bord politique et amender pour
améliorer et ici en France on n'a pas
cette maturité là en fait c'est on est
en face où on est pour on est contre ce
qui fait que là aujourd'hui en plus avec
ce nouveau Parlement et ses nouveaux
nouveaux députés qui ne connaissent pas
les règles du jeu en fait font n'importe
quoi donc on se retrouve dans une
démarche où on peut plus améliorer
et donc si on est affrontal
systématiquement quand vous avez une
majorité en frontale on prend plus rien
donc cette maturité politique et moi je
l'ai bien gagné au niveau européen et je
pense qu'ils doivent venir dans notre
dans notre système français où on est
bien entendu dans un camp politique mais
dans lequel avec ce camp politique et
notre philosophie politique on peut
abonder améliorer et on voit bien la
difficulté de LR au Parlement de la
République où là ils sont retrouvés en
porte-à-faux tout le long là la vous
parlez de l'Assemblée mais la maturité
politique que vous évoquez elle existe
au Sénat et le Sénat va pouvoir
reprendre la copie et la travailler sur
le fond dans un vrai esprit de dialogue
et de et de et d'amendement pour le coup
et que ce soit pas obstruction et de la
maison
quand même passé quelque chose mais
honnêtement la maturité de LR au Sénat
qui est d'ailleurs pilotée par un LR ce
sont des gens de gouvernement ils ont
une expérience j'étais au gouvernement
et Monsieur l'archet c'est des gens qui
sont déjà modérés qui sont raisonnables
qui pour autant sont très déterminés et
très fort dans la conviction mais là ils
vont en faire un travail de
parlementaire qui va faire grandir à mon
avis le texte
et Bruno Retailleau vous dites il a une
attitude responsable pour une entailleau
c'est pas ma sensibilité politique à
l'intérieur de LR bon mais Bruno taillot
je le respecte il a une ligne il a une
évolution il est capable de discuter
d'échanger de dialoguer de se battre
mais il y a un échange permanent ce sont
des gens qui ont une culture de
gouvernement donc ils sont dans
l'opposition mais néanmoins au Sénat ici
eux qui le pilotent et dans cette
culture d'opposition par rapport au
gouvernement ils vont améliorer me
semble-t-il dans ce débat sénatorial la
qualité du texte donc là c'est des LR
que j'aime
pas non mais j'aime pas ils sont
toujours contre tout
ça regardez ce qui se met regardez ça
mais nationale
je vais aller sur le fond
certaines nous ont expliqué sous l'air
Fillon qu'il fallait à 67 ans pour la
retraite je parle que de l'âge comme ça
on va pas là dans les détails trop trop
loin mais après on a expliqué sous
l'aire de Madame Pécresse qu'il fallait
65 ans Monsieur Prady était quand même
le supporter de Madame Pécresse et là
maintenant il est plus d'accord pour 64
ans vous croyez que les lecteurs de base
de droite peut s'y retrouver c'est
impossible et en plus retrouver avec un
schéma très particulier vous avez le
nouveau président de LR monsieur
chautier qui dit toute la journée non à
Macron non à Macron non Macron tac il
vient de se faire élire président de
l'air et immédiatement il voit que la
première loi de Monsieur Macron la
cohérence
ce qui veut dire qu'il vaut mieux qu'il
rentre dans la culture européenne voir
celle du Sénat et de dire attendez là il
y a des choses positives là c'est pas
tout noir en tout blanc c'est
l'opposition c'est pas ça maintenant
c'est plus ça l'opposition c'est
d'arriver à faire grandir les textes et
avoir l'intérêt général c'est pas de se
retrouver coincé par une démarche
caricaturale et se retrouver comme
analyser et là et c'est ce qui se passe
dans une démarche caricaturale et
coernalisée
il soutient 65 ans puis après il veut
pas soutenir 64 ans puis après il dit il
faut 64 ans et puis il dit je soutiens
le gouvernement traduit non mais je veux
pas 64 ans alors que lui voulait 65 ans
et puis finalement ils vont voter pour
mais il vire son numéro 2 attendez il y
a eu raison prenez quelque chose il a eu
raison de virer son numéro 2 comme pour
reprendre votre expression et est-ce
qu'il aurait pas dû lui faire plus tôt
par exemple bah ça aurait été plus
simple de pas le nommer mais s'il ne m'a
pas arrivé le problème donc il a su
quand le moment il se retrouve coincé
donc s'il ne met pas il aurait eu
problème à l'entrée et là il a le
problème à la sortie voyez que vous
connaissez bien que les sénatrice des
Bouches-du-Rhône nous a dit hier que le
fait qu'il est limogé Aurélien Pradet
son poste de numéro 2 ça montre qu'il y
a un chef et que c'est un chef à LR vous
êtes d'accord je parle plus de LR non
mais là vous en avez parlé quand même là
c'est la salade interne c'est leur
tambouille interne donc c'est un chef
je suis parti de LR tant mieux voilà
est-ce que ça est-ce que ça clarifie la
ligne aussi ce qu'il a fait est-ce que
ce débat sur la réforme des retraites ça
clarifie la ligne chez elle on verra
bien la position de Pradier derrière
est-ce que Pradier les siens je n'ai pas
compris ils sont dans certaines qui sont
cadres donc ils sont plus je sais pas
moi vous savez tout ça la patience en
fait tout ça c'est la tambouille interne
de chez elle s'intéresse pas les
Français pour leur retraite en réalité
ça nous amuse nous Ta sœur ici c'est pas
sérieux aura besoin des républicains
pour faire passer cette réforme
Sénat va donner son truc dans le cas on
a quand même un sénat qui aujourd'hui le
président l'archet avait assez avec sa
commission mixparitaine c'est lui qui
est le plus fort du pays en fait et donc
il imposera ce qu'il souhaite dans le
cadre de sa démarche et je connaissais
vraiment bien monsieur l'archet qui
était mis du travail sous Jacques Chirac
à l'époque pour faire en sorte que il y
a une loi adaptée à sa sensibilité
personnelle pour l'intérêt de la France
mais sur le fond vous n'avez pas
vraiment répondu tout à l'heure est-ce
que sur le fond il y a des choses à
changer dans cette réforme est-ce que
tout va tout
est-ce que vous dites aucun Français ne
doit travailler au delà de 43 ans s'il
est dans un dispositif derrière long
c'est ça me paraît cohérent ça me paraît
cohérent mais là dedans l'enjeu c'est
quoi c'est de se retrouver dans une
démarche ou on fasse en sorte en fait
c'est quoi le problème de fond qui se
pose que ça soit sur les carrières
longues que ça soit pour LR c'est que
avant sous l'air Sarko en quelque sorte
on dirait plus pour gagner plus ça c'est
il y a 15 ans quoi c'est une démarche
qui est dépassée aujourd'hui les jeunes
ils veulent savoir comment je travaille
mieux et comment je vis mieux voilà
c'est pas du tout la même mécanique
alors après il y a une promenerité ça se
comptabilise regardez l'état des lieux
il faut bien clarifier aussi la façon
dont c'est fait parce qu'on voit bien
que si quand on fait la liste de la
carrière pour toucher sa retraite même
l'administration peut se tromper parfois
non mais c'est ça donc il faudrait que
personne ne travaille au delà de 43 ans
parce que là selon l'âge auquel vous
avez commencé un coup c'est 45
c'est le débat parlementaire non plus
finir mais ça dépend quel métier si vous
commencez très tôt vous avez un métier
très pénible mais à quel moment c'est
pénible quand vous croyez qu'un micro
celui qui fait la microchirurgien
microchirurgien qui est toute la journée
debout et fait la microchirurgie c'est
pas pénible son travail
il est favorable à l'introduction d'une
dose de capitalisation vous aussi
ça va pas dans la démarche quand même
que celle de la droite depuis toujours
nous on est plutôt dans un système
social en fait qui fait c'est la
répartition donc c'est une c'est un
c'est une démarche de répartition entre
ceux qui travaillent ce qui travaille
pas et c'est donc c'est une équité
sociale la capitalisation c'est
l'ouverture au plus riche qui vont avoir
les meilleurs moyens pour avoir la
meilleure retraite c'est pas le sens de
la vie des choses je me sens en tout cas
c'est pas que sur les syndicats on a
évoqué la bataille de l'opinion la
bataille du Parlement il y a aussi la
bataille de la rue les syndicats veulent
mettre la France à l'arrêt le 7 mars
prochain vous êtes une président d'une
grande région avec des raffineries
est-ce que ce mouvement ou cette cadence
de blocage vous inquiète qu'est-ce qui
va se passer par chez vous ils ont tout
bloqué
c'est toujours les mêmes qui bloquent et
qui pénalisent ceux qui ont envie de
travailler en fait dans la même histoire
donc vous attendez cette marque non
j'apprends pas parce qu'on a déjà vécu
plusieurs fois et on sait s'organiser
mais c'est une mais ce qui a c'est que
regarder dans ce qui vient de se passer
jusqu'à maintenant les syndicats ont
gagné la bataille de l'opinion par
rapport au Parlement en tout cas et au
gouvernement grâce à des grèves qui
étaient pas pénalisantes pour la
population c'était des grèves qui ne
bloquaient pas le pays et donc
globalement les Français ont dit bon ben
ils sont corrects avec nous et très
bêtement j'ai pas envie de travailler
plus donc je soutiens à partir où ils
sont bloqués dans la propre démarche ils
peuvent plus aller travailler le matin
que les femmes de ménage peuvent pas se
déplacer que ceux qui se lèvent tôt
peuvent pas dépasser que ceux qui sont
dans le métro plus le prendre ça pose
énormément de difficultés les
raffineries c'est un autre débat
c'est-à-dire les raffineries sont des
moyens c'est les moyens
d'approvisionnement on est
station-services on fait le plein avant
puis on va venir et on s'en est très
bien sorti la dernière fois même si la
queue un peu longue
il y a
des rafies de son sont bloqués vous
allez avoir des réquisitions
c'est compliqué là-bas la réquisition
l'application de la loi dans la
réquisition est compliquée il y a un les
sénateurs une quarantaine de sénateurs
qui dont Stéphane Le rugulier qui est
sénateurs des Bouches-du-Rhône qui veut
déposer une loi pour empêcher les grèves
les week-ends de vacances et les jours
fériés vous êtes favorables
moi je crois que la loi la plus
intelligente qu'on ait pu voter c'est
quand on était au gouvernement et qu'on
avait fait en sorte que le jour de grève
était décompté de son salaire
et donc non parce que
moi je rends mal quand même au syndical
parce que maintenant ils ont été très
raisonnable dans le cadre de leur volcan
il y en a pas eu de casse ils ont
manifesté pacifiquement et légitimement
et démocratiquement respectant les
autres donc moi c'est pas ça qu'il faut
toucher c'est pas le problème il est pas
là
c'est les casseurs qu'il faut qu'il faut
combattre et donc et ce poumon
démocratique de la manifestation fait
partie de la démocratie et donc les pays
ont des manifeste pas sont des pays qui
sont pas des pays démocrates c'est des
pays autocrates donc moi j'aime bien
quand même que il a la possibilité de
liberté de passer par la rue aussi pour
s'exprimer sans rien casser on va passer
au reste de l'actualité on parle de
l'Ukraine Stéphane oui on est un nom de
un an du début de la guerre en Ukraine
cette semaine est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il faut que la France devrait faire
plus en termes de soutien militaire et
notamment est-ce que est-ce que c'est
une bonne idée de passer à la livraison
d'avion qui est demandé il y a un
principe je crois que c'est un principe
très important à poser pour les
formations politiques
que ça soit pour le rassemblement
national que ça soit pour un IPS voilà
et je pense qu'un débat au Parlement
peut être intéressant et l'enfant
dans ma région où j'ai un transformation
à très fort où j'avais un candidat
contre moi qui est pro russe j'aimerais
bien savoir normalement ce qu'ils
pensent ces gens-là parce que là il y a
un enjeu civilisationnel il y a nous le
bloc de l'oxydant avec nos défauts au
travers nos libertés nos grèves nos
manifestations la liberté des femmes et
des différences très bien
c'est notre système on peut dire c'est
le grand oxydant et dans ce grand
oxydant avec les américains et canadiens
tout ça on n'est pas forcément
majoritaire face à aux autocrates qui
aujourd'hui par l'intermédiaire de
Monsieur Poutine essaye de péter la
totalité notre système à nos frontières
moi je suis pas pour un datanga et donc
il faut faire très attention c'est une
puissance nucléaire mais celle qui a
attaqué et donc il faut quand même
absolument défendre les Ukrainiens parce
que si on défend pas les ukrainiens et
que les Ukrainiens perdent à ce
moment-là on se retrouve avec notre
civilisation qui tombe d'où l'importance
du débat avec les différentes forces et
vous savez c'est comme pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale du
rassemblement national clairement vous
doutez encore du positionnement du
rassemblement national
si vous l'avez vu claire bah je suis
content de le savoir mais qui le disent
au Parlement alors parce que jusqu'à
maintenant ils ont pas été clair ils ont
été très ambigu et leur passé montre
bien qu'ils sont très ambigus vous
évoquez monsieur Poutine il n'y a pas
que Monsieur Poutine est-ce qu'on n'est
pas en train de voir immergé un axe
clairement antioxydant qui allie la
Russie mais aussi la Chine et un certain
nombre d'État d'autres États
autocratiques l'Iran etc en Afrique qui
qui veulent mettre à bas et l'Europe et
les États-Unis donc là on est plus
simplement dans la défense
d'un territoire qui est les Ukrainiens
c'était pas quand même
le peuple le plus démocrate qui fait
démocrates oui mais en tout cas plus
organisé respectueux des règles qui soit
au niveau européen sauf qu'ils ont ils
ont choisi l'Occident
parce qu'ils aiment vivre et ils payent
très cher cette liberté et ils en durent
des moments qui sont épouvantables parce
que les Français sont capables de dire
un truc pareil sûrement enfin je moi je
pense que oui dans le sursaut général
d'un peuple mais pour autant on voit
bien que ces civilisationnel l'histoire
et donc là dessus je me méfie un peu
comme des Américains même si je suis
pour américain qui nous explique que les
chinois sont sais plus donner des armes
aux Russes monsieur Biden qui vient
là-bas j'aimerais qu'on évite une guerre
mondiale sur le continent européen quand
même c'est mieux voilà
oui à tous les risques la France elle
peut être encore une puissance
d'équilibre on a entendu Emmanuel Macron
il est au téléphone avec Vladimir
Zelinski il dit qu'il faut pas écraser
la Russie elle peut elle peut encore
jouer cette voix le rôle de beaucoup
parce que elle est membre du Conseil de
sécurité et les membres permanents du
Conseil de sécurité vous savez que
j'étais aux Nations Unies avec Jacques
Chirac et Dominique de Villepin pendant
la guerre d'Irak et le fait d'être
permanent du Conseil de sécurité fait
deux fêtes au-delà la puissance du pays
que l'on peut discuter avec sa puissance
militaire on est une puissance militaire
on est une puissance nucléaire et on a
une puissance diplomatique parce qu'on
manque de ton conseil de sécurité autre
sujet d'actualité c'est la convention
citoyenne pour la fin de vie qui a voté
dimanche 1er vote disons qu'il faut
faire évoluer la loi une tralage
majorité trois quarts des citoyens se
sont prononcés pour une aide active à
mourir vous êtes favorable alors j'ai
deux volets à moi je suis médecin
et le médecin il est fait pour soigner
il est fait pour repousser la mort pour
repousser le cancer pour prolonger la
vie et globalement ça marche bien quand
même puisque on voit la durée de vie
moyenne de vie bien augmenté ça veut
dire que la médecine avec ces médecins a
fait le travail nécessaire donc le
médecin que je suis pas très favorable
mais l'homme le père de famille ou
l'enfant de personnes âgées faire en
sorte qu'à un moment ou un autre il faut
arrêter donc quelle est la démarche donc
si on peut sortir la médecine de ça et
faire entre guillemets un suicide
assisté ou une réglementation qui fasse
attention c'est pas les médecins s'en
occuper en fait c'est la loi de s'en
occuper de façon dans le cadre de la loi
on apporte une réponse c'est pour aux
gens qui souffrent qui veulent partir
mais l'évolution de cette loi à mon avis
il faut pas y mettre les médecins les
médecins ils sont là pour prolonger la
vie pas pour la supprimer autre
actualité ça fait un mois plus d'un mois
qu'il n'a pas pu dans le pays une
sécheresse divers qui est préoccupante
alors 2022 a été marquée par une
situation climatique exceptionnelle
est-ce que vous êtes inquiet pour votre
région sud je suis très attentif mais en
même temps très optimiste pourquoi parce
que nos aînés ils avaient un problème
d'eau Pagnol avec Manon des Sources
assez remontent à plutôt Napoléon III
nous a mené l'eau au Palais Longchamp à
Marseille si on va plus loin les Romains
ils ont fait des partout parce qu'il y a
pas d'eau et c'était hier donc à partir
du moment où on réalise qu'il y a un
vrai problème et que l'eau c'est pas une
ressource simple non mais c'est pas
comme c'est pas comme le gaz ou le
pétrole l'eau c'est on a 80 % notre
corps c'est de l'eau on a besoin de
l'eau et donc si on a pu faire un
travail sur l'électricité on a bien vu
qu'on a fait des des contingences qui a
fait en sorte que on a fait 9 ou 10% de
d'économies d'électricité avec un peu
des efforts on doit largement pouvoir le
faire au niveau de la région des régions
pour nos piscines pour nos bateaux etc
mais parallèlement à ça il y a une
organisation structurelle à voir et nous
on présente ici à la région un Plan Bleu
qui est une organisation spécifique pour
le goutte à goutte pour nous verger
pour nos arbres pour nous enfin cet
étire on a souffert sur le lac de
Sainte-Croix ou il y a eu plus d'eau
c'est un problème pour notre tourisme
tout ça s'adapte il faut y réfléchir
dernière question sur la réforme des
institutions
présidents de la République a
entreprises consulter les anciens
présidents de la République et il y a le
sujet et remis sur la table on parle
d'une d'un redécoupage de certaines
grandes régions éventuellement qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que vous en pensez alors
il y a plusieurs choses là-dedans est-ce
que on découpe parce que il y a des des
endroits où ils s'entendent pas ils
veulent pas travailler ensemble je parle
par exemple du grand test où est-ce
qu'on découpe parce que on redécoupe
parce que on veut redécouper
parce que on pense qu'on était efficace
moi je parle pas des derbilles locaux
c'est potentiellement les deux aussi la
réalité là-dessus c'est que si on sait
pas à quoi sert une région c'est que
l'acte de décentralisation pour
valoriser les blocs de compétences entre
les mairies et les départements les
régions n'est pas clair c'est pareil
avec un coup de ciseaux qu'on va régler
le problème de la décentralisation et
donc il peut y avoir des territoires qui
ne s'aiment pas entre eux et qui ont
besoin de se découper mais moi je pense
qu'il faut faire comme ça existe dans
les régions espagnoles ou allemandes où
il y a des blocs de compétences qui sont
clairement affichés et on a pu voir et
le président de la République l'a dit à
l'époque dans la crise du covid les
régions à la manœuvre ont été très
efficaces pour les masques pour
l'économie etc donc pourquoi il
retoucher merci Renaud Muselier merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité la Une
de Ouest-France quand Biden défi Poutine
en se rendant en Ukraine c'est à la Une
de votre journal merci Stéphane merci de
me dire on parle régionalisme tout de
suite